hi I'm Erica Barth I'm a master's
student at the School of Forestry and
environmental studies here I was just
curious professor Nolan you said that
pre-empting drilling in towns isn't the
right solution and I'm just curious
could you elaborate on that and also
talked about how for instance in the New
York State example what happens to those
towns in New York will they be able to
maintain their band if drilling goes
forward in New York by the state and the
governor decides to lift the moratorium
the answer to the second question is yes
we will have a system a permitting
system that the state puts in place that
will give permits for companies that
follow the operational standards that
New York's Dec puts into place and you
go get a permit but you're going to have
to get a local permit as well and comply
with local zoning and where the way we
used to handle that is that we used to
permit industrial operations and
industrial areas and we have mapped
areas within our communities for those
kinds of operations what we're dealing
with now is a very radical change at the
local level of permitting drilling in
places that industrial activities didn't
use to be permitted and I'm not
proposing that we that a I don't think
it's a good thing for towns to prohibit
fracking I don't think that's a good
idea but be I don't think it's a good
thing to leave them out so see that
leads me to the conclusion that we have
to come up with new methods of
communicating between the federal state
and local level as to how these things
are regulated my thought is that the
state is never going to be able to
regulate at the level of detail that
1,600 local governments in New York need
there to be so we have to bring local
intelligence local plans local zoning
local knowledge into the conversations
on the how and I'm not exactly sure how
to work that out but prohibiting
fracking is not the right way and taking
local governments out of the equation is
not the right way